hello you're watching GameSpot daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less insert 4/20 joke here
and Callie and I'm joined by Michael
home I almost forgot about the holiday
national holiday for many of us here in
the office many of us out there in the
world happy holidays
feel like I'm on top of the world no we
went out drinking last night and we
don't do that
no we drinking tea of course oh yeah
well it was thirsty soul yesterday we
mentioned that it was thirsty Thursday
and boy was wheat there's the 40/40 and
water anyway CBS hooked us up so um
we're good it's sponsored by our company
our parent company so that's all right
drink tea responsibly we have don't cry
don't cry which relates to our first
story we have a couple things we have
actually a few related God of War
stories so you get like a triple threat
story at the beginning then we got
Disgaea I say just guys Disgaea or
Disgaea let's go with this guy huh it's
also just a shout out in ten dalabo is
out today we just got in the office
yesterday and I am reviewing it so keep
an eye out for that review sometime next
week cool you got to play with cardboard
boxes for work yeah I'm gonna decorate
them
what a life alright so the first story
we have is god of war director Corey
Barr log was brought to tears after
seeing the game's critical praise look
let's cut to mr. bar log roll site to
him crying so he's so this is a review
reaction from Corey bar log he posted
this and it's him seeing the review
scores for the first time so the 94 on
Metacritic brought him to tears and you
see he's so sweet yeah some dope glasses
I wasn't mention this earlier when we
were watching the video I was like he's
got sweet haircut he's got some dope
glasses he's got a little axe on his
shirt like he's looking at oh he's such
a proud dad I know um happy for him a
quote from him he says it shouldn't
matter but I'm just so [ __ ] proud I'm
just so lucky to work with the people
that I work with I'm glad I didn't [ __ ]
it up oh that is the most relatable
thing I've ever heard
yeah so Cory Cory Varla took I guess you
would say a lot of risks with the way
God of War went because we were talking
to the Matt Espinel and I were talking
to the team about like the design of the
actual game itself and we had a previous
story in which what is it he wanted to
do it for the Tomb Raider reboot the
single camera shot he said I want to do
it this way and they said no so that's
why God of War is the way it is and
essentially what he what the developers
were telling us is that Cory needs said
to them look we're gonna do it this way
however you can make it happen just make
it happen like we're gonna do the single
cam shot it's gonna be a third-person
over-the-shoulder it's gonna be how this
is out combats gonna be but just make it
happen
and then so for him to actually see that
vision vision come to fruition I think
that uh that's really it's neat yeah and
then he's getting very emotional about
it and then we have some more thing but
one thing I want to say is he also said
that he considered not posting that
video of him right and he said in a
tweet I debated on whether or not to
upload but I thought it would be a good
I would be a good Papa and show my son
it's okay to cry which is that's true
which is the dopest together that is
that's a man right there and also just
as a reminder that the people who make
games are human beings and they're
they're people human beings and as funny
as it can be to just just drag something
just to smithereens when you don't like
it it is you know it's people making
something this is their work but they're
you know you know how long it takes to
develop games takes years and so when
when people pour their passion into
games for for several years and get the
final product and see people play it
whether it be good or bad you know you
have to think that you know so much so
much work goes into these things they're
not just like copy and pasted from
another game and then they just like
I'll release it like that and it's you
know people pour their hearts into these
games so when you do like a game make
sure you show appreciation for that
because that's what keeps them going
yeah um okay so on that sweet note we
have related news which you've seen on
the screen if you're watching
PlayStation announced on Twitter that
God of War is getting a photo mode which
is it can be pretty funny because you
can manipulate Kratos and at races faces
so you can pause to rotate the camera
you can change the field of view a field
of vision I feel a field of view I was
right
alright yeah cool and change the focal
length you can change their faces like I
said and you can pose for shots yeah we
have some so many shots over here if
you're you're watching with us like this
look it's scrolling through Kratos his
face huh hey this yeah this is just
creeping me out
Loki but yeah so photo mode just like
horizon zero dawn I guess I had a lot of
fun with horizon zero dawn photo mode
hey you know that's a great transition
actually is it because one of the things
that happened today also is that horizon
zero dawn developer guerrilla games
congratulated Sony Santa Monica on God
of War on Twitter
what's the love going around you got a
war but yeah that photo mode I had a lot
of fun because that game is gorgeous to
it it almost screwed up my pacing with
the game because every every like five
minutes I wanted to stop and take a take
a picture take a photo photo in photo
mode and you know changing the time of
day where the Sun is well liked because
well if you change the time of day it
will change what the Sun is like though
but yeah the camera angle fov it's
really fun but for me it's like man I
have to I'm in the middle of this quest
I'm in the middle of this boss fight but
not hold on let me take a picture real
quick yeah so you have to do that what
can go in God of War which is I would
say probably the best-looking ps4 game
to date yeah yeah I've got a war stuff
because it's out today we've been I feel
like it's been out for so long because
we've been talking about it ever since
that we got it in the office and our
review went up last bolt everyone more
or less everyone's review when the
embargo lifted last week yeah so and
I've been watching everyone played here
in the office and I was like oh it came
out today so it is out today yeah I
still haven't had a chance to really
play it because I have been on other
projects and I'm really really excited
to play this weekend after all of these
positive reviews and just Cory bar log
being
being a real one be happy no real dude
all right we got we got a story on a
game that maybe will not be dead that
that's that's that's up to Bungie to
decide I know so that was mean um so
some of destiny to use exotics are
getting redesigns and Bungie has shared
previews of them this is ahead of the
war mine DLC which is coming out in May
your leave which I'm interested in
checking it out so some of these exotics
are ones I actually used a lot when I
played destiny regularly so I was
actually kind of interested in this so
in February well I guess overview of the
exotics they're changing the gravitons
Lance the sky burners Oath and racking
yes I can I can help read off some of
the changes that are coming okay I just
want to say gravitons Lance was my first
exotic in destiny too and I I do have a
soft spot yeah special place in your
heart special place in my heart for
grabs mine do you want to know how the
graviton land graviton I don't know how
to pray graviton Lance of changing yeah
we could actually you know what let's
see how it changes while you read it off
cool okay well player feedback on the
graviton Lance was largely was largely
that it looked and sounded great though
it wasn't actually all that useful in
combat especially in PvP so Bungie yes
first pulse rifle goes pulse rifles go
I'd much rather use nightshade so Bungie
reduce the recoil of the burst and added
some aim assist and changed it from
three rounds to two mm-hmm
which is weird for pulse pulse are
usually through three rounds and they
also tuned the rag dolling so that
instead of because you know the gravity
the graviton Lance like its main hook is
that it like sends enemies flying like a
gravity burst they tuned to the rag
dolling on that so instead of them quote
violently flying backwards and out of
range of Splash Damage opponents now
float back in up cool and the idea is to
give this like it has the spectacle of
an exotic but it's to make it a little
more effect effective the explosion is
also a lot bigger and with more damage
and targets each seeking projectiles
cool that's what's up run me through sky
burners oaths
both senior design on John wise new ski
said the sky burns Oh almost has the
opposite problem of the graviton Lance
it's a completely strong boy it what is
it it's a comparatively strong weapon
effective at multiple ranges strong
aim-down-sight and from the hip with
varying fire rates however it lacks
spectacle and gives it that gives it
that would give it an exotic weapon feel
so Bungie has given sky burns Earth's
projectiles explosive rounds as their
default impact response according to the
Bungie Update firing from the hip causes
it to lob slower projectiles than ABS
and at a faster rate of fire they track
targets and explode now and actually the
clarify sky burners oath as a scout
rifle if you didn't know that okay yeah
and also what were there's some other
changes being made reducing the
precision precision scaler if you all
know what that means I don't know what
that means a bit Anderson scaler as far
as I know scaler is like a programming
and like math term so it's it's actually
kind of an inside baseball term for them
to use but they they're reducing the
like precision aiming of the this scout
rifle and in favor of increasing damage
okay cool
that's dope alright and the Rat King is
actually gonna be good this time I'm so
excited about this so when destiny 2
came out we were working so hard to get
Rat King it was this whole thing rat
Kings a really complex quest and the gun
increases different stats the more
people in your fireteam I have it
equipped and are using it so one of the
big changes is that now you just have to
have it in your kinetic weapon slot you
don't have to be using it actively for
those modifiers to be active of the
stats that improve when multiple fire
fire team members equip tracking the
strongest is probably the increased rate
of fire and the quote from the Bungie
update is unfortunately the DPS
potential is hard to realize because
some people just can't physically pull
the trigger fast enough to cash in on
the benefit so they're switching it to
full auto to make that more effective
also it was no that's ok we we pulled
out racking during the raid and it
didn't go very well which is wrecking
these it was not a good gun before so
hopefully the
full-auto helps it also the stat
increasing purse purse perk will stack
more drastically for like the first two
I think it says yeah the first the first
one or to fire team members that stack
it so you can see more of a difference
with a smaller fireteam yeah
and lastly or the the base invisibility
timer of Fuhrman has all been up to 7
seconds can you tell me what that means
uh you know I don't remember because I'd
never used rat King so if you do know
what that means just know that and
lastly Bungie tees the massive work
upgrade so which says it's going to put
a tasty garnish on this meal you won't
want to miss out on which I still have
not sold on master work weapons so maybe
with war mines they'll make it more or
something I want to do and you can see
all of the updates not just for exotic
weapons in bungees update for this week
yeah if you still care about destiny 2
there are cool things on the way and
changes being made yeah alright third
story we got high school sports
association will sanction eSports but it
won't include shooters this comes from
polygons mm-hmm though oh yeah go ahead
oh I can help out with this one the
National Federation of high school
sports will soon acknowledge eSports so
eSports is real it's an actual sport if
you're not on the train and get on the
train because it's going the NFHS
administers the rules for high school
sports nationwide and mark Koski the CEO
of and if HS network says we have
continued to track eSports over the past
18 months and believe that the timing is
perfect for us
we know eSports isn't just up-and-coming
it's here like I said we believe if we
can have a partner with an eSports
focused company to help facilitate this
it is much better for students to be
behind the education behind the
education walls between the hours of
2:30 to 5:30 versus being at their home
or the friend's home so the trying to
sanctioned eSports wait wait I want to
back that up it's better for kids to be
at school and at home
because kids need to always be at school
whatever I love being at school man I
miss high school ok I suppose dope so if
you love high school too
and you're a high school kid man you
could stick around play some dota yeah
you can but not counter-strike oh yeah
that's right
they didn't name any specific games but
it'll include MOBAs sports games and
fighting games but deliberately not
including shears and costs keys quote is
first-person shooter games we believe do
not fit within the education mindset
that we were hoping to bring to this
activity I would like to point out that
white is beating the living hell out of
somebody in a fighting game why is that
better because you use your fists I
don't know I guess like it's a little
silly if I'm if I'm an administrator and
I walk by hey y'all doing that eSports
thing like if I walk by and they're
playing like Street Fighter and we're
like okay that's that's what's up but if
I see them like playing see us like
eight and I'm here in the comms over cuz
I'm Terrace yeah when I think about it
like if someone's listening to me
playing counter-strike they're like damn
what do you do I'm like ain't plant the
bomb plant the mom would want like a
what effect a good point good I'll pick
up my own four and blasted fool like
sounds like I don't know if well you
want to do that be doing that in in in
school so I kind of see what they're
getting at with this that's fair that's
fair I mean I understand because of
course the political climate if you're
in the u.s. around guns and schools has
been a it's been a lot to say police we
won't get into that obviously but that
does make sense
I just I think whatever the NFHS will
partner with play vs play versus I don't
know how you pronounce that to build the
necessary infrastructure for eSports
competitions yeah it's cool yeah so they
will allow for state competitions
individual states can choose which games
are allowed for their students States
may include an FPS if they choose but
it'll be separate from the NFHS
infrastructure and won't get promoted
okay so I guess that's kind of a nice
like movie poll yeah and tournaments are
gonna begin next year so this is
happening sooner than I had initially
thought sorry seniors hey y'all
graduating out there get into your
college eSports team I guess at Berkeley
there's a starcraft team oh yeah I
remember of when I was when I was in
high school people were talking about
like a we're going to Berkeley we're
gonna take the Starcraft strategy class
cuz I think I was like a one-unit class
in at Berkeley I was like damn one plate
actually I want to teach that actually I
should teach the excellent I'm firing
Starcraft boy yeah you did a Starcraft
anniversary 20 20 years yo that's a
long-ass time anyway
that's really cool cool opportunity for
kids to get into gaming I know that like
when I was in high school it was
definitely not cool to play video games
and I had to hide it from everybody real
quick on this note of like not having
FPS is sanctioned by the school I
remember not and when I thought about
this too is that I in Filipino class and
I think my homies will remember this
that they're watching so a Filipino
class we had to do a we had to create a
video where it's like instructing
someone to do something but yeah it has
to be in Tagalog and so I I did that
with my friends but I did like a
counter-strike guide video oh but the
thing was that we had to present it in
front of class so then me my dumb ass is
thinking like oh yeah
I was like heavy into my CS days when I
was this is a 9th grade yeah I was heavy
into my CS days and I did a video
explaining like strategies in
counter-strike in Tagalog like for my
class and so I was like oh yeah this
videos fired so I show on TV and my
teacher is like yo I don't think we
should be showing this cuz I was like oh
this is how you use an OP like oh you
gotta like get headshots and stuff and
she was like we're gonna stop showing
this video and it's and I was like I
think about it now yeah and I thought
about it like yeah my bad hey but the
video was fired hey it's really cool
that you use that opportunity to do
something with a game yeah so video
games in schools it's happening it's
that it has always been happening yeah
but just for the record it's been
there's been studies that prove that
there's no correlation between violence
and violent video games anyway we got
cool cool story for you weeaboos out
there yay Disgaea one is getting a
remake for a Nintendo switch in ps4 this
year so NIS America which they do a lot
of cool anime stuff on Ichi software
yeah that's what NIS stands for yes
it's releasing two Disgaea one complete
on both platforms so switching ps4 to
commemorate the game's 15th anniversary
beverage is really cool yeah
it's a yeah this is a tactical RPG so if
you think about Final Fantasy Tactics or
tactics ogre it's very similar to that
you know I want to show we have an image
that compares the toys let's look at
that first so yeah this is a remake of
did you say that Oh No
okay it's a remake of the ps2 tactical
RPG Disgaea hour of darkness which came
out in 2003 as you can see so this is
the original 2003 graphics which
honestly it looked it looks really cute
I like the pixel art a lot and then this
is the remake graphics which uses the
same visuals or similar visuals to
2015's Disgaea 5 and Disgaea 5 complete
ended up releasing on the switch in 2017
it originally came out for Pete just ps4
in 2015 it'll feature the same story and
gameplay as the original version so it's
not going to be changed on that front
I'll be at the improved visuals oh yeah
yeah it'll be similar to 2015's the sky
5 yeah the sky 5 complete released on
switch in 2017 so you can go you can
still play this series on this or you
can play series on the switch like now
but to get that sweet remake you have to
wait a little while
mm-hmm PC version of Disgaea 5 is also
planned for this year so if you don't
have a switch or a ps4 you can play on
PC yeah
so lots of Disgaea stuff for you fans
there's also a well get to this looking
to make also features the etna mode
which includes characters not present in
the original release
etna mode was available in the PSP and
ES remakes disguise been remade tons of
times and it's an alternate storyline
that focuses on the character Etna
instead of Lara all at no mode no games
I'm glad you got that yeah anyway
there's also a 100 dollar special rosin
Queens finest edition which I it's a
fancy title and it includes all sorts of
things including what looks like a titty
mouse pad so we can copy the game for
either switch or ps4 we got official
soundtrack official hardcover artbook
enamel pin set which is at the bottom
really kind of total Orthodox
any coaster set you know because n is a
does the pretty stuff the dude you know
the do OD is the mascot oh okay so sorry
this isn't a titty mouse pad it's
literally it says nope I Aetna flat
mouse pad was really a bit clarified
that this this got me thinking about
Shiva's mouse pad even has a Genji ass
mouse pad that's like the anime boobs
ones but it's Ganges but it's yeah it's
any he's looking back it's something I
love anime why don't you why don't you
finish yes sir sorry get the poster of
Darkness its Terra's istant posted her
and another netherworld unbound is also
tear-resistant poster I get a pretty
cute plush rose and Queen certificate of
authenticity so you know it's real
pretty pouch collector's box as well so
you can keep all your dope
Disgaea collectibles in there mm-hmm
Disgaea hour of darkness originally when
it came out received an eight point one
out of ten in GameSpot's review so this
was back in 2003 so I think GameSpot was
still doing the hundred point scale 100
point scale but also the you rate the
graphics gameplay sound and then
reviewers tilt off handles are the days
man so Greg Kasavin soften its cassava
breakfast oven oh man you Oh G GameSpot
fan hey I know all about I know all
about my GameSpot history he said at the
time it's a game that's unorthodox above
all else and filled with plenty of
cheeky humor some likeable characters a
number of intriguing gameplay elements
and many many hours of turn-based combat
this is one of those games that could
literally last you a couple hundred
hours if you let it and if that sounds
exciting rather than just plain scary
then by all means give the game a shot
even if you don't end up leveling your
characters into the hundreds or
thousands you'll still probably be glad
you got as far as you did whoa whoa I
got no time yeah that's good that's no
Greg sovereign I trust his word and if
you don't know what he's up to now he's
with supergiant games yeah
that means sweet GameSpot Laura man
thank you smile or on lock yeah and so
anyway if you've never played Disgaea
now's your chance to check it out with
improved visual
even though it's been remade several
times now you get the top not just the
newest of the new mm-hmm and you can
this is I don't I'm not too familiar
with Disgaea but if you want to start
with the first one this is a jumping-off
point because there are five main line
ones I know they have a couple spin-offs
yeah this guy has all sort of stuff I've
always liked the art style it's super
cartoony it almost reminds me of like
studio trigger animation or like like
gainax
and like it it's I just like the anime
the art style a lot so anyway there's
that we only have so much time left so
we got a speed through these oh oh
Deadpool to director I didn't pull up
the b-roll hold on that's alright
Deadpool to director and I got a delete
oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm so
stressed okay David let much bleach
bleach you mean you got these
pronunciations will direct a movie based
on the division what oh yeah sure sure
so it will have Jake Gyllenhaal and
Jessica Chastain cool yeah and the
division movie will wall game Gyllenhaal
and Chastain have been attached to the
project since the outset and are
persistent in ensuring the tone of the
movie matches that of the video game I
have a couple feelings about this I
think that the division has has an open
lore in a way I think if there's gonna
be an action movie based on a video game
the vision isn't too bad because it's
it's fairly standard premise so they
have the room to kind of take whatever
direction they want like if they want to
go with like the main line division
story like that's fine yeah but if they
want to take some creative creative
freedom with it it could be a pretty
standard or good action movie maybe this
is your chance to make a good video game
movie because it's it's moral it's I
mean it has Tom Clancy in the name it
does and you know if you watch some of
all fears with Ben Affleck and Morgan
Freeman I think they were in it that
movie wasn't that great well I mean
we'll see I mean apparently rampage
which I have not seen with the rock is
supposedly like one of the better video
game movies he was celebrating a fifty
three percent on Rotten Tomatoes he's
like yes finally a video game movies
well received I was like oh that bar is
so low no but you can yeah anyway so
there's that fun fact that was a quickie
and then
no I'm not gonna say that again um quick
story finally Tim Schafer would love to
remaster more LucasArts adventure games
this comes from PC gamer you love Tim
Schafer I do love Tim Schafer I talked
to Tim Schafer at GDC and I said what's
up to him but ya don't find has
remastered games like Grim Fandango
full-throttle
and day of the tentacle some adventure
games that I am very familiar with that
I love very deeply and Tim Schafer spoke
to a spoke at resid and said that the
team would gladly do more quote he said
we'd love to and in some ways it's up to
Disney cuz LucasArts those word
originally LucasArts games so Disney
would have to be the one to approve a
reboot but he continued if they want to
do that now obviously and if the
original creators want to be involved
that's what makes those remaster special
that of the original creators came back
and we're able to say what they want to
improve on and what to leave alone
mm-hmm so yeah it's Double Fine is I
like Double Fine I do like Monkey Island
I think Monkey Island is my favorite of
the LucasArts
adventure point and click games but yeah
Schafer says that his main main goal is
to still make new games but he does
enjoy going back to classics of course
great he says you should always be
trying to pull out new ideas but then 20
years go by for some of the go by for
some of these games it's been enough
time that there's some value in going
back and looking at classic games also
they were falling apart they weren't
available anymore they didn't run so
you'd have to pirate them if you wanted
to buy some of them we thought it was
time also the source material was aging
a lot of it was on tape drives that are
crumbling some of the team had passed
away while everyone's still around let's
make a definitive version of this game
we can get the team back together to
comment on it and gather that art go to
the archives and find we can find so I
like that it's he's taking this like
game preservation angle to it which i
think is really cool one of the cool
things about remaster games is there
there are games that are just like you
can't play anymore because they it's
hard to run on modern modern hardware
modern OS is because I know for a very
long time where like the Windows 7 XP to
Windows 7 era it was very hard to get to
actually play games
like grim fandago or like all the monkey
old monkey island games because you have
to do a lot of a lot of finagling with
like dot ini files or downloading like
third party apps that will trick your OS
into running as if it was like Windows
98 or like das or something something
like that so if there was a for a while
that was a very it was very hard to play
these old games but then with remasters
obviously not only do you get improved
visuals but you just get a simple way to
play these games and yet shouts out to
tim schafer he won the lifetime
achievement at a GDC this year yeah
anyone afterward as well he gave such a
nice speech too yeah it was is he had
like a very long heartfelt speech and
then I spoke with him backstage and
funny thing is that I asked him was like
oh um what would you say to someone who
has actually hasn't played any of your
games of the past like full throttle or
Grim Fandango and he was said he said
you know there's so many great games
nowadays so they should just move on and
play modern games like but maybe that
that was his ways like modern games as
in my remastered version yes so yeah but
I would highly encourage you if you're
into point click old-school
point-and-click adventure games to dig
into Double Fine's remasters and the
things that they're doing nowadays
because since Tim Schafer is one of the
one of the best I would say
personalities in the industry one of the
great great game creators of our time
mm-hmm right that's all the time we have
today but I do want to do a quick shout
out to you we got a new potato mode up
today if you don't know potato mode is
our show where Joey takes a partner and
they just totally break the graphics of
a game they did far cry 5 they did
crisis as well they did crisis which is
hilarious they did got a knockout of war
they did a GTA 5 yes and this today's
episodes every Friday on King spot today
is 2016 doom and that's what John Luke
John Luke psych he's a big Bethesda boy
Jonathan Lucas
Jonathan Luke guess not his name now his
name is not John it's John Luke but so
they did that so check that out it's a
fun time it's all great time
the Statham was awesome mm-hmm thank you
to Matt Padgett Tony Wilson crisper air
take Emily Conti and all of you thank
you all uh yeah this is closing out our
second week of GameSpot daily we are you
know we're working work shopping things
continually trying to get better making
sure that we're prepared better and yeah
we do this we do this for y'all and we
hope that you will stick around for us
as we improve our show because we have a
lot of people who are who are happy
doing this this makes this makes us
happy and I hope it makes you happy if
we have fun you have a good weekend
goodbye we'll see you Monday enjoy your
Friday and be safe
come back next week because we're not
going anywhere goodbye